>>Georgia: I realize how
much more they learn,
so when I see that they take action
and they're applying the skills
that they learn in here, I feel
like I've done my job as a teacher.
>>At your service, all right.
>>Monica: Inquiry based learning is
just a fancy word for curiosity, right?
So tell me what child is not curious.
>>Georgia: We as humans all
question, that's how we learn.
So the students should be
questioning all the time.
>>Jonathan: Any questions?
>>Mary Beth: We're trying to
ignite passion and relevance.
It's not just about finishing that
assignment, it's about being able
to explore something that
I'm really interested in.
>>Monica: The basic steps in
inquiry based learning is to come
up with a rich question, a question that
doesn't have the answer already in it.
>>Georgia: You begin with the questions
that you really want to explore
in a unit, and then each
unit has lines of inquiry
that the students will be investigating.
And the lines of inquiry are developed
by the teacher but with a lot of input
and feedback from the students.
>>Mary Beth: And that
becomes the direction
that the teacher takes the content,
so the teacher will resource kids
with opportunities to explore
things that they're interested
in within that line of inquiry.
So kids are hitting the standards with
the bigger questions and being able
to create evidence of their
understandings and their learnings
in all kinds of ways that
the kids get to pick.
>>Georgia: So for instance, we're
doing a money unit right now,
we're studying billionaires.
The theme billionaires was not
chosen by the teachers per se,
it stemmed from the students' inquiries.
When we were going through
the inquiry process
and they were asking
all these questions,
a common theme that kept coming up
was, why are some people so rich
and other people are not rich?
>>I remember a lot of you were
wondering why some people don't have
as much money, remember that?
>>Students: Yeah.
>>Georgia: So those questions
led to our investigation.
>>We had a huge discussion about why
we're studying billionaires and it's not
because they're super humans or
that they're rich or they're cool
because they have a lot of money.
We're looking at character
traits and we're talking
about what do these people have that
enables them to be this successful?
>>Student: You're doing a
keynote about Ralph Lauren's cars.
He has a giant car collection.
>>Bobby: We're asking ourselves some
questions and then we would have looked
on Wikipedia and searched
up the questions.
Maybe one day we want
to invent something.
>>Student: This right here is how
Warren Buffett influenced society
about what he did, how much
money he gave to charity.
>>Student: How about this one?
>>Teacher: Why would I really care about
someone donating money to a charity?
>>Student: Because she helped someone
and then she built a school for girls.
>>Mary Beth: We're opening up
learning by letting kids decide, "Hey,
what am I really interested in science?
What am I really interested
in social studies?
in literature?"
giving them a whole list of potential
things and letting them do the inquiry
and research and make those connections.
>>Jonathan: So if you have a dystopia,
you could say that "Hunger Games"
would be one of your resources
because it's a fiction story that
actually plays out in a dystopia region.
>>Inquiry based learning actually
makes you think, essentially.
You're still doing it
in the common core way,
but you're actually picking
what you want to learn.
>>Mary Beth: All of a
sudden, our students,
we see our students doing things
that really matter to them
and they're excited and they're
passionate and they want to talk
about what they're learning.
>>Monica: They're inspired,
they're reflective, they struggle.
That is a true education.